bonjour bienvenue dans génération europe
aujourd'hui avec un étudiant européen
nous allons parler de la jeunesse que
fait l'europe pour sa jeunesse et bien
nous en parlerons avec notre invité
aujourd'hui qui est jean marie le pen
président d'honneur du front national
est aussi député européen
bonjour à tous alors pour commencer
puisque on parle de la jeunesse vous qui
avez tous une petite vingtaine d'années
vous représentez la huit personnes en
réalité il ya 100 millions de jeunes
dans l'union européenne
aujourd'hui quelle est la tante de la
jeunesse par rapport à l'europe par
exemple james toi en tant qu'anglais en
tant que james que tu es qu'elle est en
attente
il ya deux choses je pense qu'il faut
avoir des meilleures conditions de
formation et deuxièmement on a besoin
d'eux pour l'europe d'organiser
l'économie pour inciter les entreprises
d'embaucher les jeunes pour essayer de
créer à une nouvelle génération des
jeunes qui sont vraiment qualifiés pour
participer à l'économie
parce que en ce moment alors on est en
train de créer une génération perdue au
plus tôt que dire on va mettre les
formations au service des entreprises je
préférerais qu'on dise on va mettre les
formations au service des besoins des
populations en fait à mon avis ça ne
sont plus cohérents pour se développer
un accord ça veut dire que passager les
entreprises et les populations c'est pas
quelque chose qui va encore n'ont pas la
même chose en place une entreprise sa
vie sa mère ça disparaît les populaces a
fait travailler les gens ça fait
travailler les gens mais les populations
et reste une entreprise ça peut être là
pendant un moment on peut avoir besoin
les populations avoir besoin de plus de
numérique de plus de 6,2 plus de ça mais
les populations elles sont toujours là
ils ont besoin de services publics
elles ont besoin enfin iliad il ya des
besoins élémentaires qui perdure en fait
alors on va revenir à l'essentiel du
sujet ce qu'elle fait aujourd'hui
l'europe pour sa jeunesse c'est
l'essentiel c'est fait par thierry
scharff mise en image par hugo nicolas
en europe le jeune se fait de plus en
plus rares comme la plupart des pays
développés les pays européens sont
confrontés à un vieillissement de leur
population
en europe les 10 24 ans représentent 19%
de la population en amérique du nord
c'est les 21% en asie 28% et en afrique
33%
l'union européenne s'est intéressée
tardivement à la jeunesse il faut
attendre maastricht en 1992 pour que le
manchot naissent figure dans un traité
l'action de l'europe ne vient qu'en
soutien des politiques nationales
alors que retenir de l'action européenne
pour la jeunesse tout d'abord une
politique très volontaire au sujet de la
protection des droits des enfants et des
adolescents et une politique destinée à
favoriser les échanges et la mobilité
initié en 1988 avec le programme
jeunesse pour l'europe en 1996 création
du service volontaire européen
il permet à tous jeunes de 18 à 30 ans
de s'engager dans une action d'intérêt
général par exemple social humanitaire
ou écologique pendant une période de
deux à douze mois dans l'union
européenne ou à l'étranger
mais le dispositif le plus emblématique
est sans doute erasmus 27 ans il a
permis à denis blanc d'étudiants de
goûter à la mobilité européenne
depuis janvier il s'est transformé en
erasmus plus et souffre enfin pas
d'autres populations comme les apprentis
et les jeunes en formation avec à la clé
un budget augmenté de 40%
l'europe voit dans la mobilité et
surtout l'éducation une des principales
solutions à la crise qui aujourd'hui
prive d'emploi un jeune européen sur
quatre pourtant elle consacre 10% de son
budget à l'éducation lorsque le régime
français y consacrent 7%
alors on va revenir sur ce qui a été
évoqué les questions de mobilité
d'erasmus on va revenir longuement sur
la question du chômage des jeunes
particulièrement temps kroumen
aujourd'hui passer des examens en
roumanie venir en france allez ici ou là
est ce qu'il ya une harmonisation des
diplômes
est ce que tu peux passer d'une
formation à une autre facilement il ya
différentes système de parallèles entre
les universités ya différents types de
partenariats entre les universités
européennes
surtout après le nouveau système de
boulogne avec le système de crédit
transmissibles quand on reçoit des
crédits pour un cursus et après on peut
compenser avec d'autres matières dans un
autre pays on peut facilement principe
est étudié un master en espagne
facilement avec les systèmes bologne il
ya vraiment une harmonisation cds credit
suisse qui vient de se mettre en place
mais le problème c'est que c'est nous la
première génération qui va vivre
vraiment tous les avantages de tous et
sister ici angola mais il a commencé
dans la fin des années 90 qu'on soit 99
c 'est traduite en fait la politique de
l'union européenne là dessus parce que
le processus de bologne à la fois il a
mis en place ce système de crédit mais à
la fois il ya plus de cadre national des
diplômes mon diplôme que j'ai eu à paris
8 il n'est mais il n'a pas la même
valeur que le dip que le même diplôme
d'histoire à lyon et ça ça pose un
problème parce qu'on suit pas en quoi il
ya différents employés les différents la
formation l'intitulé la formation qui
est dispensé le contenu qu'on tape donc
en régionaliser on s'éloigne de plus en
plus de l'europe selon toi mais je sais
pas si on s'éloigne de nous on s'éloigne
pas l'europe parce que cette europe là
qui a imposé sa en fait c'est des
directives européennes ces processus de
bologne en 99 stratégie de lisbonne en
2000 et europe 2020 maintenant qui vise
avoir des diplômes de plus en plus
territorialisée en lien avec les
entreprises mais uniquement liens avec
les entreprises est variable rien mêlé
century ça c'est vrai qu'on répond aux
marchés là il a un peu des raisons parce
que c'est pas une chose qui s'est pas
seulement en france mais moi j'ai perçu
à la pr moi qui se passe dans tous les
pays de l'europe l'espagne ça s'est
passé un monsieur c'est pas la même
valeur qui est un diplôme qui est fait à
madrid comme des planqués fait assez
vieillot à malaga si on n'a pas les
mêmes formations n'a pas les mêmes
diplômes on va pas les mêmes droits
c'est tout juste comme un vrai manche
mais en revanche je voulais dire que par
exemple commencer l'envers
et quand on a un diplôme européen par
exemple peut poster hope you still et en
france pour le capes par exemple les
certificats d'aptitude au professorat
si je prends mon diplôme en italie et je
viens postuler pour les capes en france
ça pourrait être que de ce côté là il ya
une harmonisation des diplômes qui va
proposer à notre invité de venir nous
rejoindre pas forcément pour parler de
cette harmonisation des diplômes mais
pourrait pour continuer à discuter de la
question de la jeunesse en europe
merci jean marie le pen de nous
rejoindre si les députés européens élus
dans le sud est sur la liste fn et qui
se présente donc pour ces élections
européennes
bon je vois là bonjour monsieur je trais
si vous permettez peut présenter
rapidement je peux vous raconter ma vie
ça serait trop long à oui on a une
défense à la journée mais par rapport à
l'europe
oui d'abord que je suis député européen
depuis 30 ans j'ai été au début de ma
vie juste après la guerre à ses
partisans de l'europe
j'ai même menthe et je crois la première
opération humanitaire de notre continent
en amenant 40 étudiants en 53 lors des
inondations de hollande 40 étudiants
pendant trois semaines sur les digues de
hollande
c'était original à l'époque aulas et
j'ai été cependant voté contre le traité
de rome en 57 les dépanner et j'étais
déjà député moi et j'ai voté contre le
traité de rome non pas que ces
dispositions sont dispositif économique
pouvait me gênait mais parce que j'avais
lu coudenhove kalergi et j'avais lu
monnaie qui disait ceci est la première
étape d'un processus qui doit nous
conduire aux états unis d'europe
à l'instar des états unis d'amérique je
trouvais que c'était une idée folle et à
combattre et au fur et à mesure de mon
déroulement de députée européenne je
suis devenu de plus en plus
eurosceptique au point de croire que
l'europe est en train d'amener le
continent à la ruine
c'est pour ça que vous vous représenter
c'est pour ça vous vous représenter
leurs représentants à la tête de la
liste sud est est absolument pourquoi je
suis allé jusque puisque les sondages me
donne cinq élus je suis pas si mal placé
que ça ah non ça c'est sûr mais meilleur
mais je comprends pas la logique en fait
pourquoi par rapport à l'union
européenne le fait pourquoi parce que
qu'il faut être partisan d'une société
quand on ne peut pas la combattre on n'a
pas le droit d'entrer dans un parlement
pour défendre la paix moi vous savez
monsieur
veut pas représenter le parlement
européen je veux représenter les
français au parlement européen avec
l'opinion kg du parlement européen et de
l'europe en général
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
sceptiques en france en l'occurrence le
fait que la jeunesse ne soit pas
forcément très présente dans les
préoccupations de l'europe
en tous les cas pas avant 92 et qu'on
dise que finalement ça reste en soutien
des politiques nationales est ce que
vous pensez que c'est un bon équilibre
sur un plan il a peur que la politique
soit faite par les jeunes n'est ce pas
moi j'ai été le plus jeune député et ma
petite fille a été la plus jeune députée
dans l'histoire de la république mais
nous sommes ultra minoritaire par
conséquent ça n'est pas nous qui faisons
la politique et je dois vous dire que
vous devez penser que l'âge moyen de
l'europe c'est 40 sort à bientôt 47 ans
et que en démocratie c'est la majorité
qui l'emportent
par conséquent la politique sera fait en
europe par les vieux qui rompt tous
pensent intérêt à se défendre plutôt
qu'à promouvoir l'avenir de notre belle
jeunesse qui devra bien se défendre tout
seul
sidi bouzi attendre et ça sera dur à se
défendre de quoi à se défendre pour
vivre pour survivre pour ne pas être
esclave ceux qui n'ont pas sonné comme
un sifflet dessous mais dès qu'ils de
tous de l'invasion du monde sait que
l'on vous sert de leçon
nous sommes honnêtes des enjeux communs
le problème de chômage de la formation
de tout ça c'est un enjeu commun dans
toute l'europe et on doit tout seul
lutter ensemble
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que vous
pensez je comprends vos préoccupations
qui sont personnelles de carrière
personnelle vous allez devoir faire
votre vie moi j'ai une vue un petit peu
plus geopolitis yen si vous voulez le
maître mot de l'avenir c'est la
démographie
l'europe est un pays sous nataliste nous
sommes 740 millions sur sept milliards
d'individus une somme un dixième du
monde et nous avons un âge moyen qui est
dix ou quinze ans plus élevé que celui
de la moyenne mondiale
par conséquent je dois vous dire que je
suis de ceux qui pensent que le temps va
être très troublée et qu' il va
déclencher des torrents migratoires qui
vont essayer de survivre on ne peut pas
leur reprocher ni leur en vouloir
en essayant de gagner ce qui pour eux
radeau de la méduse c'est à dire
l'europe et cela ça va provoquer à mon
avis un changement de population
jean marie lasson là-dessus qu'on
prépare donc allé en chine je comprends
pas ça fait des décennies que vous tenez
ce type de discours sur l'immigration
sur le fait qu'il ya des torrents
migratoires que vous tenez ce discours
depuis longtemps maintenant
pourtant l'immigration en france et
reste stable c'est environ deux cent
mille entrées sur le territoire français
pour cent mille départ et dans les deux
cents mille entrées il ya cinquante
mille européen donc en fait la vague
migratoire que vous après disait et les
coutumes n est pas loin vous prêter
quelques fois le train en banlieue n'ont
jamais j'habite en banlieue invités
emballé ça veut ça nous a semblé le
paysage humain n'a pas changé vous ne
voyez pas la différence qu'il y a non il
ya des protections mais vous oubliez
quand même les 250000 naturalisations
par an qui sont retirés de la masse
général des étrangers ça n'est pas le
regard est passionnant vous avez
parfaitement le droit de penser alors il
ya la question de l'immigration dont
vous parlez la démographie est ce que
c'est ça le seul sujet sur lequel il
faut se concentrer quand on parle de
jeunesse aujourd'hui non on peut parler
de tout alors nécessairement c'est ça
qui va dominer la vie de cette
génération qui va devoir faire face à
une situation dans laquelle l'europe ne
va cesser de s'affaiblir
si l'âge moyen de l'europe et 47 ans
dans 20 ans qui va occuper de ces
personnes quand ils sont à la retraite
on a besoin d'eux des flux migratoires
on a besoin de gens pour pouvoir payer
les retraites on a beau nous on sera pas
assez nombreux pour pouvoir payer vos
retraites faire subir ces volets chargé
de payer vos retraites bat on a besoin
comme à la reconstruction de l'europe
on a bien dit à des travailleurs du
maghreb et du portugal qu'ils étaient
les bienvenues pour pouvoir contribuer à
la reconstruction de l'europe
aujourd'hui on a si ces gens veulent
rentrer sur le territoire européen
on peut leur dire qu'ils sont les
bienvenus est ce qu'on a besoin d'eux eh
bien écoutez je ne crois pas moi je
crois que malheureusement nous devrions
retrousser nos manches et faire nous
mêmes le travail qui est à faire parce
que c'est nous le faisons faire par
d'autres ce sont les autres qui nous
conte imaginé mots qui vont pas se
borner à gagner vos retraites
ils vont aussi vouloir bénéficier de la
situation donc ils vont provoquer alors
revient la question de la formation est
ce que vous avez l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui en france mais aussi dans
d'autres pays d'europe
finalement on crée beaucoup trop
d'intellectuels de cerveau et pas assez
de jean-manuel et que donc du coup ça
pose un problème de forme alors je dois
vous dire que quand le président
pompidou avait justifié l'entrée des
immigrés il avait dit nous les faisons
entrer proposé à la baisse sur le train
sur le salaire des travailleurs manuels
c'était exactement l'inversé de notre
programme qui pensions qu'il fallait
rapprocher les rémunérations du travail
manuel des rémunérations du travail
intellectuel parce que c'est ce seuil en
particulier ce qu'ont fait les allemands
par l'apprentissage sont positives que
nous n'avons pas fait avec un effet une
université qui est largement ouverte à
des bacheliers disons deux niveaux au
mot bien qu'ils trouvent dans
l'université a un statut social pendant
1 2 3 4 10 15 ans la dame qui avait noyé
sa petite fille jada n'a pas marché ils
en ont résulté
elle était étudiante en l étudiante en
psychologie je crois à la 38 ans
répondent oui mais à beaucoup d'autres
étudiants petit je ne sais pas mais ça
va vraiment être énormément
il ya des universités suisses diversité
américaine
veut-elle pour rentrer ben c'est pas
facile vers une sélection
alors qu'en france par exemple n'y a
aucune sélection quand on a le
baccalauréat ont remballé diversité et
on peut y rester indéfiniment dans
d'anciens statut des oisifs somme toute
survivants qu'est ce que vous proposez
pour améliorer la situation à
l'université alors c'est une question
d'économie générale
si les entreprises ont donc répondre
fait par l'emploi pour l'emploi ont fait
l'emploi au service d'une production
vendable si possible et c'est donc il un
problème d'économie générale
si vous fabriquez des cadres dont on
sait à l'avancé qu'ils n'auront pas
d'emploi parce que l'économie un son
état non seulement n'en fabrique pas
mais n'en fabrique de moins en moins
mais c'est le procès le problème des
emplois les entreprises
non sans les entreprises européennes
sont en train de parachuter les emplois
des jeunes qui pourraient être créés en
europe dans les pays émergents par
exemple le vietnam chine inde pour la
main d'oeuvre qui est beaucoup moins
chère main d'oeuvre peu qualifiée alors
tu attends tu es en train de te dire les
romains ont peur de la main d'oeuvre
chinoise comme on a l'habitude de dire
en france par exemple qu'on a peur de la
main d'oeuvre roumaine ou polonaises toi
tu dis nous on a peur de la main
d'oeuvre chinoise et vietnam est aussi
mon chéri tout d'accord avec ça parce
que le en roumanie certes il ya une pas
pour ça mais dans l'europe dans une
grande partie de l'europe occidentale
l'entreprise revienne on recrée de
l'emploi et il ya des dizaines des
centaines de métiers manuels qui ne sont
pas délocalisables structurellement
parce qu'un chinois de ne ne soit pas
donné l'opportunité d'apprendre ses
métiers et ses des métiers qui vont de
l'ouvrier au technicien supérieur les
artisans et pour lesquels il ya de
l'emploi et c'est en france et dia il ya
des dizaines de milliers d'emplois dans
l'hôtellerie qui sont des emplois
qualifiés à bac + 2 parfois davantage
qu'ils ne sont pas pourvus donc c'est
avant tout une question de mentalité le
chômage n'avait pas appelé à rester à
25% pour l'éternité
on va continuer à parler de la question
du chômage on va continuer à parler la
question de comment on prépare la
jeunesse ou monde qui change donc en
réalité c'est ça j'ai d'abord on va
regarder justement ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de l'union
européenne contre le chômage c'est toi
jules qui a été enquêtés parce qu'après
on est allé interroger une économiste un
syndicaliste et un porte parole de
l'union européenne sur la dernière
annonce de l'union européenne sur la
question des jeunes quoi c'est la
garantie jeunes n'ont donc on regarde
tout de suite et on en reparle juste
après
jules 23 ans officiellement étudiante en
histoire est avant tout un mordu de la
politique depuis ses 17 ans est un
membre actif des jc les jeunesses
communistes
et s'il sait c'est pour nous à
l'apprenti journaliste c'est pas un
hasard non plus je veux devenir
journaliste en novembre dernier s'est
tenu à paris le sommet européen sur
l'emploi des jeunes est sorti de cette
grand messe une mesure phare la garantie
jeunes en effet aujourd'hui un jeune
européen sur quatre est au chômage
il ya urgence
il y a 6 millions de chômeurs en europe
c'est trop alors mesure bidon ou
traitement de choc
bien envoyé jules enfin bon c'est pas
sortis du premier coup la garantie jeudi
mais non c'est pas une garantie
une gare une gare une mesure phare la
garantie jeunes allez soyons sérieux
jules aux quêtes et je suis en duplex de
bruxelles avec le porte parole de la
commission européenne
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer en
quoi consiste la garantie jeunes en fait
au niveau européen on ne proposait des
réformes structurelles pour que dans
chaque état membre dans les quatre mois
après qu'un jeune a quitté l'école ou
perdu son emploi en lui propose soit un
travail de qualité soit le stage soit en
apprentissage ou la formation continue
la garantie jeunes a déjà été mise en
place en finlande et en autriche mais
c'est la confédération européenne des
syndicats qui a poussé pour que cette
mesure soit généralisée partout en
europe
thibault webber était là rendez-vous à
la cfdt avec une zone euro syndicaliste
convaincu il ya un enjeu très fort à
mettre en oeuvre une garantie jeunes au
niveau européen parce qu'on sait que
l'entrée sur le marché du travail c'est
le moment où on risque pour beaucoup de
tomber dans la précarité et portait les
stigmates je dirais de la précarité tout
au long de sa carrière
la garantie jeunes ça doit être proposée
à chaque jeune quelle que soit sa
situation qu'en tireront ce marché le
travail un accompagnement vers
l'activité vers la formation
bref qu'on lui propose des solutions
pour nous ça doit être un droit c'est à
dire que ça doit pas être juste un
dispositif qui profite à un nombre de
jeunes définit comme c'est le cas en
france on dit cent mille jeunes nous on
demande à ce que ce soit un droit
universel et que chaque jeune qui
rendent sur le marché du travail
puissent en bénéficier
quelle que soit cette situation et quel
que soit son pays à nantes la garantie
jeunes est loin de s'appliquer à tous
les jeunes
elle concerne aujourd'hui les 18 25 ans
les plus en difficulté issus de régions
avec un taux de chômage supérieur à 25%
malgré ces restrictions la plupart des
experts remettent en question son
financement
quelle est l'efficacité d'un tel
dispositif nous allons demander l'avis
d'une économiste
bonjour juge enchanté du coup l'union
européenne a annoncé 8 milliards d'euros
dans la garantie jeunesse est ce que
cette mesure va avoir une réelle
efficacité
on peut en douter assez fortement pour
deux raisons d'abord parce qu'on n'a
toujours pas de croissance si on a des
taux de chômage très élevé en europe
ça veut dire que quand on essaie
d'encourager l'apprentissage ou les
emplois aidés
les entreprises ne suivent pas derrière
puisque aujourd'hui est donc plutôt des
sureffectifs bon et la deuxième raison
ce sont les montants psion été allouée
donc huit milliards c'est lumière sur
deux ans en réalité donc ça fait 4
milliards par an donc sachant qu'on a 7
million et demi de jeunes en europe
aujourd'hui qui n'ont pas d'emploi n'y
ait de formation bon ça veut dire que ça
fait à peu près 500 euros par jeune en
difficulté par an donc c'est vraiment
trois fois rien et c'est beaucoup trop
faible en tout cas pour permettre une
réelle réinsertion sur le marché du
travail
j'ai lu tu as été convaincu non pas du
tout en fait pour plusieurs raisons le
projet initial c'est de faire de cette
garantie jeunes en véritable droit un
droit inscrit dans le marbre quoi chaque
jeune aurait droit à droit à pouvoir
trouver du travail après quatre mois à
trouver du travail voilà avoir des
offres de travail ou sinon avoir un
revenu l'idée est séduisante l'idée
séduisante entendu droit mais là
actuellement comment ça va être appliqué
en fait il ya quatre milliards par an
qui vont être appliquées c'est 0 05 % du
pib européen
en fait ça ne suffit pas pour
l'appliquer à tous les jeunes il
faudrait 21 milliards par an et la c 4
milliards donc là moi il me semble que
cette annonce elle a été fait pendant un
grand sommet c'était moi je pense que
c'est vraiment un écran de fumée en fait
c'est un dispositif parmi tant d'autres
qui à être perdu dans les langues des
dispositifs européens je crois ça pose
la question parce que si on fait le
calcul en gros de ce que ça représente
par étudiants par exemple en france un
tel cas un tel dispositif ça
représenterait à peu près 2000 euros par
étudiant par an en france quand on voit
qu'un contrat d'avenir c'est vingt mille
euros par an est-ce que du coup ça
montre bien que la souveraineté
nationale que vous prenez temps et bien
finalement elle est là par delà tout ce
qu'on peut penser l'europe comme comme
beaucoup de mesures européennes cette
mesure phare est une loupiote destiné à
amuser le public pendant quelques
semaines quelques mois puis s'inspirera
comme dit monsieur dans les sables ce
sera oublié on passera à autre chose
mais ça montre que la france reste
souveraine dans la gestion de son
éducation
espace souveraine du tout des pays sont
de moins en moins souverain et c'est
précisément ce qui me gêne c'est la
raison pour laquelle moi je suis pour
l'europe boréale celle qu'il irait de
brest à vladivostok et qui serait une
europe des nations de nations
souveraines mais mais cohérente une
union des nations et pas du tout une
union à ta vocation fédéralistes qui a
prouvé son échec qui est valant le mur
et qui continue d'y aller quand même
donc chacun des efforts de l'europe là
c'est en notre faveur c'est pour les
jeunes chacun de ces efforts vous
trouvez que c'est pas bien
l'europe essaye de faire les efforts
pour nous mais c'est pas bien elle fait
des efforts pour nous avec votre argent
à neutre où vous y trompez pas avec
l'âge c'est avec l'argent des nations
que l'europe fait de la politique
cette donation mais moi je pense que je
m'en tiens à un moment donné de grands
dangers
il faut compter sur plutôt sur les
réaction salvatrice de l'égoïsme
national chaque pays se défendra le
mieux qu'ils plus que je constate
aujourd'hui c'est que les pays qui ont
été ravagés par la politique financière
européenne comme la grèce comme c'est à
ces pays-là se vident de leur population
et en particulier de nos étudiants des
étudiants il ya 10% des étudiants grecs
qui sont partis des gens ressemblent les
étudiants français aussi d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'il faudra aller droit de
travailler à l'astoria ce sont des gens
compétents formés qui peinent bien
développé son travail à l'extérieur
parce que la richesse est que ces
personnes là forme et capable de donner
sa force de travail à l'extérieur ça
c'est une richesse pour le pays qui les
reçoit je vois que les pays ont besoin
de leur jeunesse et dont ils ont besoin
de leurs cadres mais alors penser à la
jeunesse je pensais vraiment que la
france parce que vous parlez de danger
de nombreuses reprises la france c'est
quand même un petit pays sûr dans le
monde il ya des énormes que cinquième
puissance mondiale
oui mais vous savez coup de tête mais
vous savez quand même sur l'histoire
peut-être
voilà je suis souci est un tout petit
pays oui mais vous pensez pas que la
jeunesse peut se défendre tout seul
la jeunesse française face à danger que
vous venez de nommer mais oui mais il
faudrait il faudra qu'elle se retrousse
les manches et qu'elle ne se laisse pas
bercer par des illusions
il faut qu'elle sache que l'avenir va
être terriblement dur terriblement dur
et qu'elle s'y prépare à tout point de
vue intellectuellement moralement c'est
très logiquement mais avec l'europe
on va continuer à aller plus avant dans
la conversation mais je vous propose
d'écouter la question de notre
partenaire technique hearts et olivier
malnuit qui vous pose une question
aujourd'hui ce sont surtout les jeunes
qui payent le prix fort de la crise avec
des taux de chômage souvent
astronomiques pour y remédier l'europe
propose une solution
la mobilité professionnelle à
l'intérieur des pays de la communauté
européenne
est-ce que malgré toutes vos réticences
à l'égard de la politique de bruxelles
vous ne considérez pas que l'europe est
la plus fabuleuse opportunité qui
s'offre aux jeunes aujourd'hui pour
sortir de la crise je crois que cette
mobilité va reconduire à aller à partir
des des pays à faible rémunération par
les vers les pays à hautes rémunérations
appauvrissant d'autant plus les pays acp
petite rémunération ce que le
mondialisme relayé par l'europe est en
train de faire c'est l'installation de
l' esclavage dans le monde entier
ce sont les pays qui travailleront le
moins cher possible on arrive à
travailler au bangladesh à 40 euros par
mois et il espère délocaliser pour
essayer de trouver un pays où on
pourrait travailler à moins de 40 euros
par mois je trouve que cette démarche
suicidaire mais la globalisation et est
un fait semble-t-il est ce que l'europe
du coup n'est pas une organisation n'est
pas un fait l état et l'amour et de la
mondialisation est en partie un fait pas
fait mais le mondialisme est une théorie
qui consiste à aggraver c'était ses
formes d'uniformisation du monde contre
lequel je suis dressé comme un puck sur
ses ergots
j'entends alors simplement est ce que la
question de la mobilité entre les états
européens fait qu'il n'ya pas une
disparité par exemple de proposition
d'offre de travail qui peut faire qu'en
français aura du travail
je ne sais pas obéi baby doc si le
français va aux pays bas ils prendront
la place derrière ces étudiants des pays
bas alors que je suis actuellement en
train de travailler aux pays bas donc
tout ça c'est fait toute l'histoire de
l'europe est faite comme ça
les pays européens se sont faits par
osmose de citoyens d'autres pays qui
préférait venir dans tel par exemple 10
italien préféré être en france et en
italie sont devenus des français ces
inondations mais culturellement comme ça
non alors justement donc cette mobilité
c'est quelque chose d'assez logique par
rapport à elle a toujours existé
qu'est-ce qui empêche cette mobilité
voilà qu'est ce qui empêche quelqu'un
d'aller faire des études en allemagne
bosser les moyens et du coup l'europe
permet par exemple erasmus qui a fait
hier à smith ici voilà qu'est ce que ça
vous offre
c'était une très bonne expérience pour
moi erasmus
j'avais une bonne période de ton ma vie
et c'était très enrichissant
enrichissant pour moi j'ai profité de la
vie espagnole
ouais on est lassé ville et j'ai aussi
arrondi méconnaissance et je pense que
ça a aidé à mon nom ma personnalité
aussi ça vraiment si vous êtes étudiant
en langues en plus ça a dû vous aidez
moi je comprends très bien ça mais c'est
une des petites réalisations de l'europe
c'est comme le débat c'est comme le sait
comme le service européen 7000 personnes
bon faut pas non plus se leurrer sur le
nombre de millions d'étudiants europe ne
se fait pas en une semaine en une
journée ça soit combien de temps les
biens à sa prendra peut-être des
décennies série 10 mois et je vous dis
que ce sera fini avant longtemps journée
change des pronostics mais blair a
smooth la bourse erasmus et amener vous
parce que comme un jour j'ai dans la
même ligne qui l'a 10 à mettre en
contact des gens de différentes cultures
et du coup tu vas pas être seulement en
contact avec des français c'était en
france mais a levé des aliments de
romans des sites alliant des gens de
tout leur report alors c'est un grand
rendez vous et on doit vraiment a perdu
leur offre l'avant parce que ça va créer
une génération comme elle un autre d
europe 1 qui serrait ça ensemble pour
lutter contre tout le problème que dans
l'armée
il portait aussi je vais travailler des
mains en italie j'irai s'il va revenir
demain à travailler en france il viendra
c'est comme ça c'est le repos qu'on veut
on découvre brusquement la l'humidité de
l'eau les voyages forment la jeunesse
c'est vieux comme le monde ça ça date
pas d'aujourd'hui et que c'est qu'une
des grandes réalisations de l'europe
au prix où ça nous coûte soit d'avoir
favorisé race plus ça me paraît vraiment
le minimum minimorum une petite
conclusion jean marie le pen par rapport
à tous ces échanges avec cette jeunesse
européenne qui se sent si européenne je
pensais avec une certaine angoisse parce
que j'ai des enfants j'ai des petits
enfants et je pense à leur avenir
je suis inquiet parce que je vois que la
différence de démographique de notre
continent
la russie paiera millions d'hommes
parents et pardonnez moi l'allemagne est
un cercueil en or ces riches ça marche
mais ces composés de beaucoup de
vieilles personnes qui vont vieillir de
plus en plus la grande révolution du
xxème siècle n'a pas été tellement la
révolution scientifique et technologique
elle a été démographique le monde est
passé de 1 à 7 milliards d'habitants en
un siècle et demi et ils galopent vers 8
vers 9h10 milliards et alors que
l'europe elle ne cesse de perdre sa
population par conséquent de vieillir et
de s'affaiblir voilà la vérité à
laquelle vous devrez faire face et je
crois qu'on y fera face mieux dans des
réflexes de nation e amicale à l'écart
les uns les autres
le je crois que le niveau des changes
avec l'allemand entre la france et
l'allemagne est le même qu'en 1914 par
conséquent on n'a pas changé beaucoup de
choses dans les échanges
en gros c'était il ya eu deux guerres et
puis finalement maintenant il ya eu
derrière
bien sûr certes y'a eu de guerre et
quelques et combien meurtrier etc
rassurez vous il y en aura d'autres
vient un côté l'europe justement et là
contre ça merci beaucoup jean marie le
pen merci à chacun d'entre eux bientôt
pour un nouvel épisode de génération